jesus oh my god
my russian's a little rusty but that
scared them out of me
i think i think they proved their point
so guy i i found i actually thought that
the first ad wasn't bad
but it's very touchy feely should we be
embarrassed
about our privates
uh look i found the the cartoon
animation to be a little bit
strange i think that just as an american
citizen i'm more concerned about
military
readiness than equality or inclusiveness
i don't think that they're mutually
exclusive though
right um what i was distracted by was
this
wedding and you can ask cat i will
attend any wedding even if i'm not
technically invited
right so i kind of want to go hang out
at a wedding like that that seemed sort
of appealing
yeah yeah you were a cat's wedding
weren't you i was yeah
by this power girl was a guy so yeah the
flower girl was a guy
yeah yeah in heels and it was not me
just to clarify the flower girl was not
god it was not it was a guy
it was one of her one of her buddies
well you know let's just try to get this
back on point bill i don't know why you
have to die for these topics
my feeling is i mean half of me thinks
whatever works and half of me thinks
i you know there's a lot of tough
marines who want to eat your face
yes and uh probably
a different spot so
what do you so how do you i mean if you
were in charge which
ad would you prefer to use uh i would
use option number two yeah and i'd say
spasiba
oh stuff wow
the only russian you know probably three
words i could buy with that
yeah um i i think it's interesting
can you say whether or not this would be
a campaign
that would be used in the cia or the u.s
military
if trump had won a second term um
no he'd probably rail against it he'd
probably make it i think the answer is
no
yeah so uh here's a theory i i i do
realize we're
probably comparing something that's
internal well i don't know maybe that
was russian internal too to there to get
people to join
so i always get i'm getting the feeling
that this this
touchy feeling is is a protection racket
so that people
will let be less inclined to think of
the military as something dangerous
does that make sense i mean it could be
it depends on also what they're
recruiting for so we had that cia video
before and one of the things that a
retired cia agent told me is that
that you need to that would add was
focusing on
latina women okay so the reason is
because apparently china is kicking our
rear ends in
latin america america and they need to
recruit
um people that will be able to blend in
when they're undercover
so i don't know what they're recruiting
for and this young woman that um said
she found her calling she's working for
the military
maybe she's a cyber security expert if
you figure out how to kick the
butts of dark sides oh you think it
might be smart i don't know i don't know
what they're recruiting for but i have a
feeling they wouldn't be wasting their
time there's got to be analytics behind
it
right or some explanation beyond just
walkness
or it could be maybe like cartoons it
could be animators
yes yes although i gotta say that cat
maybe because it's i'm a masculine male
that i was more taking very masculine
very very masculine i was taken by the
russian ad
no it spoke to me yeah the seeing any
sort of woke anything is always kind of
weird but
especially this one you're watching it
and it's all you know
identity politics and girl power and and
fluffy and
you're watching it you remind yourself
this is a recruitment ad for the world's
most powerful killing machine
yeah that's my point yeah and then it
gets a little weirder and also i just
married a veteran so
like as someone who's half veteran thank
you for your half veteran
and now half veteran by marriage no i'm
obviously do not mean that
but i've talked to him a little bit
about his experience serving in the
military and he tells me stories i gotta
say
sounds pretty hard like yeah some of the
stuff you had to do i'm like what you
know like you had to do that and
it sounds so crazy so i just think that
you know
as she's explaining it is something she
did you know how could you possibly do
that she said she did it because
you know her sorority life wasn't
fulfilling and she wanted an adventure
and her sorority sister was in italy
i feel like the way my husband explained
it to me and i think the way most people
would explain it is that you do it for a
reason other than yourself and putting
your country over yourself and
that wasn't mentioned here at all why
didn't he uh re-up your husband
uh he didn't re-up oh i don't know
because he didn't want to
get to that part of the conversation he
wanted to spend time with cat you know
not much of a veteran
maybe a half a veteran yeah i mean we
have to share it now
50 because we got married i mean i
identify as a veteran without ever
serving
just so you know all right